All right.
Hey,
what's going on it's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
September.
Now February 12th.
There's a fucking comedian.
I don't even know whether I didn't know where the fuck I am.
February 12 2018 what's going on?
How are you?
Um,
usually,
usually I do these by myself.
Usually I'm just sitting alone by us.
Like,
you know what?
Fuck this.
My buddy called me up,
he's got a podcast he wants to promote and he's a fucking eagles fan.
So I figured why not?
I got to go on because for some reason people think I actually fucking hate
Philly.
Just cause I got booed there because of that video.
Yeah.
And it's just like,
no,
I got booed in Philly if I,
if he got booed in Texas.
What are you,
do you make fun of fucking pickup trucks,
chicks with too much makeup?
All of it.
I just make fun of Texas in general.
I think everyone just goes to Texas.
My goal to stay as Kentucky,
I like tech.
Well it's Kevin Shay,
everybody from the,
uh,
the Kevin Shade podcast.
All I'm saying podcasts,
all I'm saying that's,
that's easy.
Right?
So I remember,
do you know every host and it also kind of gets you off the hook or whatever you
just said.
Exactly.
I all I'm say
it says too many people.
I didn't mean to specifically pick out that group like they needed to go,
but there's too many fucking people.
I mean hosts fucks it up though.
It's,
it's kind of funny cause they go,
they go with you in trouble.
All I'm saying podcast,
all I'm saying,
I'm saying,
I said you can read it so easy.
They asked two more times before they go on stage and they go,
oh,
I'm talking about what you doing,
how's it going?
And so we know you didn't like getting all Sassy.
Yes.
And we always bet the other,
and all I'm saying isn't really a,
that's pretty mainstream vernacular.
I,
you know,
I didn't,
I thought it was a fucking kidding.
A title is hard.
Like you have the best title ever.
It's just doing,
yeah,
it's simple.
It's so simple.
That's why I did it.
Is that why you remember when it would come out funny and then people go,
we should do want every day of the week.
It's like,
well then it's not the money you got the Thursday,
do the third Thursday just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
Um,
I love when people just,
they go fuck it all out.
Yeah.
Like you show up at this,
some of these comics studios,
you feel like you're doing Howard Stern.
I don't want to be like,
dude,
you could really keep you overhead weight.
I look,
I'm not talking about guys like rogue and Mike Rogan in,
we'll have like,
you know,
fucking super,
super famous people.
I'm just talking just like,
oh it doesn't mix a jerk off like me and I'm having you over there a reason why
you're not in my house right now because my daughters,
I figured that I figured cause your daughter's sleeping and then I didn't,
I didn't know you moved.
Like when you texted me the address to the studio.
I know,
but when you texted me me or you made this,
this,
no,
you.
Yeah.
You,
when you texted me,
I was like,
why would he move to per bank as like,
that was my,
I was like pill and I was like,
you're doing well.
You got more bang for getting more bang for my buck out.
Say,
why would you move to where,
man,
I liked valley.
I
like the value.
You're getting better,
better conversations out here.
You know what I mean?
You meet some guy who did something on mash way back in the day.
A bunch of Trump supporters,
you know?
No.
Then the Hillary stuff gets old man in Hollywood.
It's like,
I get it.
You know what I mean?
I want to hear it.
I want to hear somebody actually thinks something good's going on.
I love it.
I fuck even make it a better every day.
My brain takes better.
That's Taco tastes better.
I don't,
I don't really talk to a lot of people.
You know that about me.
Well then why did you come down here for you?
It's just cause your team just won the Superbowl,
the e a g l.
E.
S by the way.
I eat.
I'm a fucking huge eagles fan,
but I hate that fucking song.
The fight song flow.
How does it go?
I own no fly.
Oh it has to be old,
right?
It's not,
it's fucking not.
I did a whole research,
I thought it was from like 1920 or 18 cause it's not fly.
Eagles fly when I see that.
Sounds like it was written the same week of for,
he's a jolly good fellow
back when that wasn't corny to say.
It's,
it's weird cause it's supposed to sound,
oh it's got the boom boom boom.
Like the jobs up front and go get him.
I hit him low so I looked it up razzmatazz 1985
or something like that.
Maybe that is like 30 years ago.
32 years ago.
Fuck.
I guess you put it this way.
If you look,
if you were in 1985 right now and that song was 32 years old,
they would have been written in 1953 yeah.
Oh Shit.
But I gotta be honest.
You hit them high,
hit him low is very like still like that sounds like it's written in the 40.
[inaudible]
it sounds very college.
Very,
no,
not knowing college.
Like high school.
I would say college.
You still call it won't be too,
too hard.
Oh No.
I love the song.
I love,
here's the thing.
It's one of those songs where I love it,
but I acknowledge as corny.
Okay.
Jimmy is cheesy,
but I love fly eagle.
Fly Up up to this gap.
Is it like a disco remake and like getting uncomfortable?
You singing?
No.
Fucking sing yourself.
Do you know,
uh,
the Po by,
he's a jolly good fellow.
He goes one the fucking Superbowl number one.
Uh,
we were going to,
Breyer is like years ago I had to lock all of those gigs out yet [inaudible]
does drives,
we hate those fucking jobs.
No,
I swear to God,
Dude.
I almost like was ready to fucking just leave la yesterday.
No way I did.
I did go,
it was like fucking Saturday.
It was a Saturday afternoon and I was,
I can rush hour traffic and you want to get mad but you're going to be like,
well I'm also out here and they're all do this fucking nobody is fucking talking
about doing something about this population problem.
And uh,
I'll tell you one thing we have to get a problem of is touching the desk and
hitting this.
This is going to be annoying in this.
We have a new podcast studio here.
Oh Shit.
Why are we doing that?
No,
no I,
I just,
I've been hearing it so we're going to have to put some sort of padding here.
I don't know what,
but anyways,
I like nature,
right?
I enjoy like animals in
that type of shit.
But I always have my,
my,
I never take the remote out of my hand when I want you to nature show cause
right when they start talking about what's going on with them and how they're
all going to die off because of us,
I shut it off.
Well my daughter always,
you know,
takes the remote and it's amazing.
My fucking remote sucks.
I can literally be pointing at the TV,
like change,
change,
what the fuck?
I won't do anything.
My daughter picks it up and he's like walking away with it and we'll,
we'll somehow turn on the fucking DVD player.
I still have one of those.
Um,
is it digital?
Is the remote all digital with like,
no,
I have direct TV and I love direct TV,
but they're remote sucks.
You look at it,
you have to fucking reboot the thing.
It's like,
it's like a,
it's like it was in a abusive relationship and it's over sensitive.
I feel like it was recycled.
I'm like some racist had it before me was constantly throwing it at the TVS.
Funny.
And then they just like,
you know,
like our,
all our old phones that you watched a bunch of porn on an aisle over there and
like Thailand or the Philippines.
Do you know why he told you?
Did you have a I have a laptop that I use.
Just report.
Oh yeah,
that's,
I just said,
so that is
a very specific jazz proof or something.
It's just the hard drive.
So maybe on a latex it's just so old and shot.
So I don't give a fuck if he gets diseases early suddenly.
Yeah.
Fuck yeah.
I don't care.
It stays at separate,
but it's old is big isn't it?
You know what that reminds me?
Have you ever see these people that get like foster kids and they feed their,
they're real kids and they just take the checks for the foster kids and maybe
the kid will look like he's fucking eight years old and really bony and you'll
be a cup holder and he's like 26.
So that was a thing that is a thing.
Oh,
feed him like fucking paste and shit.
But here's was confusing when I was younger.
I'm a,
I'm adopted.
I never,
it doesn't surprise me the irritating,
I don't know the difference.
I didn't know the difference we foster and adopted.
Okay,
so you thought there was like foster kid means,
uh,
you just take them for a little while,
right?
Yeah,
but they were always like abused and I was never abused and I couldn't wrap my
brain as a kid.
I called my parents,
mom and dad,
but then my friends down the street who were a family,
but they were divorced with kids,
call them by their fucking names.
While it's great to hear,
that's why they got a divorce.
They were never committed.
They weren't committed to each other.
They weren't committed to having a kid.
It weird like when they would call their mom by their first name.
Well My,
well,
my daughter learns how to speak.
I'm going to be like,
this is mister shade.
She's not going to call you Kevin.
I don't like that.
I don't make it.
Ain't a fucking can't stand when people do like my buddies,
we'll talk to you.
There are other parents and they say,
Hey John Paul,
it's weird.
It would help if we kind of dressed like adults though.
I mean you gotta you of me.
I go,
you're an adult.
It's not,
you don't have a no.
You know what it was.
No,
but back the day like you know,
people just to fucking like if you want,
I was,
I tape recorded all,
like they had all the NFL films,
Superbowls in a row on NFL films and I taped all 51 of them and I'm just working
my way through them.
I love them.
I can't get an awesome,
they're awesome.
So I was watching them and first of all,
like the first,
like 11 bowls were played in like the afternoon.
I know they played it like rice stadium at two lane,
you know what I mean?
And there was just like,
like I like the fucking college band.
Like what if I'm like the Michigan marching band went out there and play.
Did it?
Uh,
the niners I thought you was scatting horn.
Did it
even start doing a band or something dumb?
You're my fucking head.
Okay.
Didn't a bed if
the liners,
yeah,
they played in Golden Gate Park.
Yeah.
Give me a ships and probably an NFL championship,
but you guys sucked back then.
So I don't know.
I think you had like one good year in the forties and 50s.
I said no,
there was one,
it was one in the 50s,
in the 1960 was the last one.
And we used to,
we always get into this discussion about,
uh,
like you think it matters what the NFL championship,
NFL title should count.
They do count,
but they're not super bowls.
And you know,
I don't get that.
I,
you know,
there was no one in the league.
I get it.
But now there is another league.
There's no,
they're still was,
there was,
there was still a fucking no,
you don't understand.
The AFL started in 1960.
Before then there was,
there was only the,
no,
there was the NFL and then the AFL came in.
I'll give you a little history lesson.
The first year,
the AFL,
okay,
all the NFL owners laughed.
Baja Ha,
look at these fucking morons wasting their money.
But while they laughed at him,
they then they made two moves to fuck over the AFL.
The first thing they did was,
um,
I think the team with the most amount of money was,
was that was the Dallas Texans.
They will read and white,
right?
They let him,
he became the Kansas City chiefs.
So what the NFL did was immediately or,
uh,
gave Dallas and NFL franchise.
That's how the cowboys started.
That started so that there would be a team in the same city as the wealthiest
AFL team.
They're trying to cut the head off the snake here.
So then basically the figure in both,
they're going to be low quality of,
of players because they're both brand new.
However,
you could see Jim Brown or whoever,
like the superstar that day was,
would come in and play the cowboys.
So you're going to go that game rather than the Dallas Texans.
And it kind of worked because the Texans ended up moving to Kansas City and
became the chiefs.
All right.
Then the other move they made was one of their franchises.
The Minnesota Vikings were initially going to be an AFL team and they came in
and they said,
hey,
uh,
you want to join the NFL?
And then they said,
hey,
fuck the AFL.
Let's go with this team.
So that's what they did.
They tried to fuck over to teams.
That's what they take.
Now the NFL continues.
There's all these fucking championships being one.
The Green Bay packers won like fucking 13 of them and they're the New York
Yankees.
They're the fucking Celtics.
They're the,
they're the Montreal Canadians of football,
but they just don't recognize their first 12.
So they say the Steelers,
I was six Superbowls.
So in 90,
after 1969,
when the jets beat the fucking,
uh,
hackers know colts,
they beat the colts.
And um,
there was a merger talk was already there in the AFL was actually doing so well
and was such an exciting product that it was kind of looking like they might
actually might take over the NFL.
All right.
And the only guy who had the balls to say fuck the new NFL merger deal was,
uh,
was,
was what's his face there?
Jesus Christ.
It just based on his name,
uh,
with the Raiders.
Oh,
out Dave Al Davis out there.
It's this fuck that.
He just didn't want to beat him.
He wanted to bury him.
He wanted to put them out of business and everybody else was like,
no,
fuck that.
Let's join.
So they joined.
Okay.
Now that has happened in other leagues.
The Nhl with like the Ihl with Wayne Gretzky's where the fuck he played with
India?
Uh,
Indianapolis like um,
I guess that was his first team.
I used to know all of this shit.
But they,
they've absorbed teams from other leagues.
The NBA took in Aba team.
Yeah,
but they they,
but they still count the Celtics championships but they didn't change the name
of the title.
I think it's cause of the event.
You changing the name of the title.
I will.
I'll go with this.
Maybe that's what it is.
I haven't thought of that because you're changing the name of the title.
The basketball never changed the name of the top.
What is the thing?
The first two green bay one out with the NFL AFL championship game as was the
third one,
which,
which jets?
The jets was so AFL title game,
which was great.
But you know what's funny about the whole story?
You heard?
You just told me.
No,
just say it.
Oh my God,
the vikings still suck.
But the,
you know,
the Patriots now have tied,
they've lost the most super bowls.
But they also,
they don't,
there's also the thing is we've also been to the most,
you've been fucking 10.
We're five and five.
Your,
you've been a tech.
Here's the thing I saw is not an elearn fell fan out there that wouldn't take
that except for the steel is steel reserve or the 49 is in the uh,
the 49th and the cowboys,
cause they already have five and they put like eight or something.
There's been five Seversville Denver last five because one three.
So they've been to eight
cowboys have one five and they'd see they lost to the colts.
They lost to the Steelers twice.
I think that's,
I think they'd been to eight.
Do
you?
I saw him clip on when they've been to a morning and you go,
oh I've been through five of these losses.
I'm like,
how old are you?
Cause the first patriots Superbowl [inaudible] 86.
Okay,
that makes sense.
Cause I was,
I am old.
I'm turning 50 in June.
Well congratulations.
I turned,
I turned a 42 on Friday in America.
Yeah,
you look great.
Thank you.
Considering how much both of us drink.
I mean,
yeah,
we're both in good shape too.
I know,
I know.
This is the sucker digs podcasts.
So anyways,
uh,
before we get into your big win,
cause I really,
cause I gotta be honest with you,
I actually as a spouse,
I'm old enough to remember when all the Boston team sucked except for the
Celtics in the 80s.
But then Len bias died and Reggie Lewis,
Diana was just fucking over.
Um,
I,
I remember what it felt like the first time.
So I was actually,
when the Patriots were not looking good to me.
Okay.
You know,
when we played the Steelers and we had the game won and we let up that 90,
we let up 90 yards on a screen pass and then the first year they want,
no,
this year,
this year in December we did that.
Oh,
against the playoff team.
And then they threw a touchdown to win the game.
But the NFL now is like,
oh,
when he had the ball,
did he really have the ball?
So it's not a catch.
But that was,
that game was a fucking lost and that gave us home field advantage and that
helped us fucking go the simple go to Superbowl.
Yeah.
So here was the thing,
my,
I was kind of watching you guys.
Yeah.
Cause I was just going right,
who am I gonna root for?
I was like,
oh la rams would be cool if they got something.
The fucking eagles would be cool cause they never won out.
So here's the thing,
if my team is in fucking in it,
I'm going to root for the team.
That is all,
there you go.
I'm going to do it.
I'm not a dick.
I didn't tell you I'm not a dick.
All right.
So,
but you know,
if it's the Yankees fuck the Yankees and if it's the cadence,
fuck the planes and if it's a Lakers,
fuck the Lakers.
But other than that,
I've got to ask you why,
why are they Canadians?
Oh Bruins Canadians is okay.
Used to be a huge rivalry.
And what happens is,
is one team never wins it and then the other team always wins it.
And then,
then what happens is then you win it and that's the end of the movie.
Then the credits are rolling like they tried to make like the red sox Yankees
thing.
It's not the same.
No,
it's over and it's Kinda like,
you know when they make the sequel but the star in the movie doesn't sign on to
do it again.
Yeah.
Or bike back in the day when like a movie,
like Major League too.
Without Wesley Snipes.
They took Omar Epps,
slashed all.
He was a,
okay.
There you go.
Well I would say at Major League without Charlie Sheen.
Yeah.
Okay.
This third one then.
The third load or jaws,
three d jobs three just to the second Spielberg goes,
Nah,
I'm not doing it.
It just became a,
became a good lay.
It
was that the one,
what was the one where the sharks started roaring?
That was the third one,
right?
It was going like [inaudible] is coming out with the one.
The fourth one is one that's bad.
Okay.
That's bad.
Aaron,
you knew that.
That's hilarious.
He just,
he was so immediate with the four.
I was like,
that's why that's so fucking funny.
Everybody looks at Shark Nedo like it's this worst thing ever.
It's like,
no,
do the groundwork had been laid.
But I like that movies.
But let's get back to this world.
I,
so I was going to sit there and you know,
you know,
I've got a lot of friends yourself.
Like I have a good half dozen people that I know that are from Philly.
You know,
I,
there's a lot of cool chicks and Philly to shake.
The women will fill your cool.
Yeah.
So I wasn't going to be that fucking,
you know,
asshole.
So anyways,
so you guys beat us and now you know the deal,
you lose a big game like that.
You go on radio silence.
I'm not going on fucking the Internet.
I mean I kind of still have to because of the podcast,
but I'm not going to watch ESPN so I didn't get to see you guys.
My favorite thing ever is,
is fucking grown men crying over sports is the funniest.
Like that Eagle's fan who called them with Carson Wentz went down.
Did you hear that?
I didn't see that one [inaudible] going to happen for us,
man.
He was,
the funny thing is the sports casting,
it's like freaked out.
He's like,
Hey,
he's like,
buddy,
you're crying.
He's like,
oh,
well we'll win it next year,
man.
Relaxed.
So flight.
Did you see the guy
who's waiting at the fence
when they won the Superbowl and when they're landing just to watch?
He was crying.
He was like a 54 year old black dude just sobbing.
Yeah.
Why sobbing?
He's just like my whole fucking life.
My whole fucking life everywhere.
And here's the,
that Patriots Kinda got me hurts.
Like way less now.
They kinda got me.
That hurts way less now knowing that somebody's an eagles fan ended up being
that fucking happen.
Come on,
man.
We fucking,
we're trying to with drowning and rings over here,
Kevin.
But here,
here's the thing.
Your first one,
you know,
you know
game.
Oh,
shut the fuck up.
People were losing it.
Oh No,
no,
no.
Everybody like we were in the exact opposite end zone.
Uh,
and he like kicked the field goal.
And I remember I put my hands out like I was holding back a crowd on Beatlemania
and my role cause my brother and dad when they was like,
oh fuck,
oh fuck.
And it went through and it just,
I,
I couldn't believe it when I went through,
then I saw the confetti and all of a sudden,
next thing I knew I was on the ground,
what it just a whole section just tackled each other.
Oh that's fucking insane.
This fuck.
And then I was worried about my dad because I was saying to my dad and he was
like in his sixties at the time and he got up and he just,
he couldn't fucking believe it.
Right.
And I looked over and there was one guy still standing up and he was just
standing there and I looked over and he was for some reason staring at me,
he just had tears in his eye and eye eyes kind of locked.
I had to like,
oh I hit it,
go
away.
Like dude,
what the fuck?
And I remember walking out of the stadium like just cause I,
I went to the one week when we lost to the packers,
so I know what that feeling feels like.
And then when that one it,
but that wasn't close though.
That one.
It was until the opening of the half.
So to have two.
So I basically had faith through fucking 18 and a half games.
So yeah,
it was close.
And then they kicked the fucking ball off and Tyrone Wheatley is out on,
that was his name.
Desmond Howard.
I know,
I know.
It was a kicker to win a fucking MEP,
a super kick returner kick returner.
Yeah.
So he ran the fucking thing back right at us.
That's,
I might've been in the same end zone.
I Dunno.
I both times I had,
I had upper deck end zone seats.
So then when we want it,
I was thinking like every time the Patriots go,
I'm going at such a great experience.
So the next time we played,
I believe you were playing the panthers and I was going to go,
but it was on Sunday obviously.
And then that Monday we were shooting the world series of dice sketch in the
morning
for a Chappelle show.
Okay.
So I couldn't go and I went there and that's the first time I met Charlie Murphy
,
rest his soul.
And uh,
I remember being pissed that I was psyched to have the acting work.
Obviously it's like to be on the Chappelle show,
but I was like,
fuck man,
I really wanted to go to that game.
But I remember when the game was over and I was in my apartment,
we won.
I was psyched that I still had two grand in my pocket.
I was like,
wait a minute,
this is kind of fucking cool.
So then I was just like,
yeah,
I don't need to go.
I saw the first one ever.
Why am I going to go there and use up a ticket somebody else could have.
And like someday,
you know,
if I have a kid now I have a kid.
If she ever wants to go,
I'll take her and I'll do that.
But other than that,
you know,
I'm on the road all the time.
Did you,
you obviously get the feeling.
I don't,
I don't know if I'd be like if I was at the Superbowl,
my buddies went,
uh,
they lost it.
They lost their minds.
But they actually came back immediately and watched the game cause they said
they couldn't really believe it.
Yeah.
They call the leave at one or two.
They didn't really see what was going on.
Well,
you don't get the analysis in the breakdown and all of that.
Let me ask you this.
When,
when Brady fumbles the ball and you guys recover,
man,
dude,
what did you do dude?
But by the way,
are you thinking like,
fuck,
he's going to drive down the field,
we're going to lose?
No,
no,
no.
I never,
this is just crazy.
Normally with all the egos teams,
I'm like,
ah,
they don't got it right that we're stomach feeling.
But this team,
it was just this,
this year and I saw destiny.
They lost their fucking quarterback.
I'm getting misty eyed thinking about it,
but then I was like,
ah,
it's not about Tom,
it's about the eagles.
That's how it felt this year about this team.
So when I didn't like how you guys all ran out as a team and everybody will show
the wins like we've been doing that you stole I fucking by.
That was our thing.
By the way.
I think it's stupid.
Well,
when you guys did it to now I think is stupid.
I love the intros.
I can't miss.
It was like,
if I got to tell you,
dude,
we went,
we've,
we've gone,
we've gone five and three doing it that way and we've been to eight of them.
So you might want to keep doing that.
No one else was driving me nuts.
Or is Chris Collins with flicker flipping out about that trick where,
well,
one of the most unbelievable fucking thing.
It's like,
don't we just ran that fucking plate.
But
here's the thing I saw,
I saw that clip and you,
uh,
when you were calling you said,
oh,
we should tell would have laid out.
I wish he caught it and the only reason cause I wanted to get,
and I wanted him to get hit.
Oh,
you just,
just like,
can I be honest with you?
Yeah.
That guy.
Every fucking super bowl has driven us down for the wind.
Everyone,
you know,
and I actually looked at all the super bowls and I would say that we very easily
could have been seven and one and the one game we should have lost was the
Seattle gets.
Yeah.
Just given it to Marshawn lynch,
both giants games.
We had Brandon Welker boom.
First down over a Satay Sam most intercepts the fucking ball that hits them at
both hands.
Yeah,
we got that one.
But that assate Samuel.
But this eagle's one
minded.
I was pretty fucking John by the end of it,
by the end of the game.
And I just,
I'll tell you,
I never felt good about this.
I'd never felt good about the team or the game going in.
I said,
I believe I sent every podcast,
take the eagles in the points and the points.
Yes,
yes.
Yeah.
And I thought you guys,
I has had an unbelievable defense.
I'm like,
these guys,
this is looking like the fucking giants do.
Where was the defects in that game?
It was like a fucking pro bowl,
by the way.
I've watched the game four times afterwards just to watch it.
Only Tom could have done that against that defense.
You know what's funny is I was watching some of those fucking passes and how,
how he got out of the pocket.
Only Tom could have done that.
Well against that defense because most of the most lie,
most I'll have to wine.
I'll have to watch it again because I didn't think you guys do and I thought
both quarterback's head like all day.
I don't think you've really got to break fucking nick falls had all day.
Tom got hit like 12 times,
but your line was better than most.
Yeah.
We just didn't have a TV.
I tell Ya,
I,
I would never question our coaching staff of the Melcor.
Anytime we do that,
I'm at that time Wes Welker like made all when,
when,
uh,
what's his face find out he had the foot fetish.
Rex Ryan so welcomed us.
This whole interview,
like sort of giving him shit going,
you know,
hey,
we're just a,
you know,
you're playing the jets.
What?
He says,
yeah,
we're gonna put our best foot forward.
That,
you know?
Yeah.
It was funny.
And then they kept him out for the first court.
Anytime we do that,
I don't know if we've probably done that other times,
but it just reminded me of that game.
Be Like,
oh,
we're fucking with the chemistry here,
but,
but I'm a stand up comedian Kevin.
I'm not a fucking offensive coordinator.
So what our defensive coordinator,
what do I know?
But I watched that game four more times.
Like I said,
oh,
so that I still have the fucking Seattle and the Atlantic.
You still still on my fuck.
I still have it.
I bought and I got the thing.
Never erase them.
My wife's like,
you never going to watch.
She's like,
yeah,
you are.
Yeah,
you will when you're bored or you want to get your fuck his spirits on.
Has she goes to bed early?
Dude,
I just say,
I'm never going to watch this.
I just take the highlights of all 51 foot.
It's like this five losses in there.
Well for losses.
Now we've got a fifth one and I'm still going to watch those.
No,
it's,
it's the best buy.
I,
I'm trying to the Superbowl 20,
we were up three,
nothing against the 46 defense.
Tony Franklin,
speaking of feet,
his bare feet came out and kick one.
And I'm like,
yeah,
you know,
I don't know.
There's a talk and all this shit.
Or two.
That was the most dominant defense that I ever saw.
Here's a good one.
Superbowl six Superbowls six is the Dallas cowboys in the Miami Dolphins.
What's interesting is his office,
Tom Landry and Don Shula to legendary coaches.
But when that game went down,
they were both considered losers and like one of them is finally going to get
the monkey off the back.
Dallas had the thing,
they could never win the big one and they'd only been around since 1960 but they
lost the ice bowl up in green bay.
I know,
dude,
I'm a fucking nerd.
And then the year before they played the colts,
they got there again and they fucking lawsuit Colton a really messy game.
And then Don Shula,
his big thing was,
uh,
he was,
when he was coaching the 69 colts that lost to the jets,
the first NFL team to lose to an AFL team was a major embarrassment and a,
that ended his career there.
And then he went over to the dolphins.
Wasn't that the undefeated season?
No,
no.
They went,
they went three years in a row,
one,
one of a,
I think two teams to ever go through years in a row.
And only one has ever gone four years in a row.
And that's the,
the bills,
uh,
they lost to the cowboys and then the next year they beat the,
they beat the red Thea.
They beat the Redskins.
That was the undefeated year.
That was the year that they hadn't before.
There was 14 to nothing.
And they would line it up to kick a field goal.
This is how much of the NFL has changed.
It's like there's like two minutes left in the third quarter,
and if,
if this thing goes through,
they like the gut announcers are going,
this game's over.
It's in the third quarter.
Yeah.
Cause no one's going to score that cuts through it.
All I did was fucking run cause they were like greasy was four for four in the
first quarter.
It's funny.
Do you know,
I I love,
I love the fact that back then how much cocaine those guys did.
Do you,
did you ever see the cocaine cowboys and,
uh,
the one that's not a movie,
it was a documentary.
It was about,
you know,
the cocaine chancellor.
What the cocaine in the Superbowl or wasn't it about cocaine trafficking,
cocaine trafficking.
They tell the story about the Steelers and the dolphins and the AFC championship
game or sealers in the Super Bowl in Miami.
That entire old line went out the night before and the guy gave them all the
coke.
They wanted up to like four more.
So a jail bird trying to get into a fucking documentary,
right?
No,
no,
he was,
he was the main guy.
Well,
here's the thing though.
They also,
uh,
like the medical industry,
whatever you call them,
said cocaine is no more addicting than coffee or caffeine.
Yeah.
So that's what they initially said.
If you ever want to read,
uh,
an unbelievable book,
read the Hollywood Henderson.
He was basically the Lawrence Taylor before Lawrence Taylor and he got crazy on
drugs.
And the reason why Lawrence Taylor looks like he just fell out of the sky and no
one ever played the game like that is because Hollywood Henderson messed up his
career so bad.
But there's highlights of that guy.
That guy was unbelievable.
In fact,
I believe Super Bowl 10,
1976 when he played,
when the cowboys played the Steelers,
they kicked the ball off.
He's a linebacker.
They had him return it and he ran it like 55 fucking yards.
The only person who stopped and was Roy Cherrella dove to knock them out of
bounds and had his ribs exposed and Henderson's knees hit him in the ribs and it
fucked him up.
And it caused darella.
This really interesting caused him to fuck up a couple of kicks in.
So that was a big thing for the cowboys,
but they fucked up.
Cause when one,
the second miss or something or the first or second Miss Cliff Harris from the
cowboys gets in,
you're Roy his face going like,
hey,
you fucked up buddy.
And uh,
Jack Lambert was on the field and just picked fucking cliff Harris up like a rag
doll and throw him under the ground.
Like basically it's amazing.
Yeah.
And didn't get a penalty.
There's another thing too,
when you watch those old that back to,
hey,
knock it off fellows.
Yeah,
they didn't give a fuck.
Telmate's they bought at Sears.
Dawkins is videos of him.
Suplex and guys,
well,
here's the thing.
The cowboys had that fucking game one in the first half.
They call all these trick plays.
They were loose.
They were throwing the ball,
doing all that.
They got in the second half.
They played fucking Marty Ball.
And I'm telling you,
man,
no fucking sport fucks you more when you play.
Not to lose than football.
I don't know what it is.
I is,
the Falcons are doing a great,
and granted Tom Played fucking lights out,
but you know how to do.
That's a,
that's a colossal,
it's a cops.
That's,
it collapsed.
I mean,
you know more about football history.
I'm more recent,
but uh,
I don't know shit about football.
I've just watched a lot of video on it.
Like I watch Superbowl highlights the way Tom Brady actually watches to him.
By the way,
I'm a film,
I don't want it.
Here's the,
I like Carson Wentz and you must love Tom Brady.
I don't want to see their personal life.
I don't,
I could give is no,
I'm not built that way.
I don't like pre or post game analysis.
Yeah.
I don't like any of that shit.
I don't want,
as I sit here talking about the girl,
no,
but I don't want to human moments.
I don't,
this is how fuck,
I don't want to see him as human.
I just want to see them as athletes.
Here's the thing.
I think they're entitled to their privacy.
I think that you should be able to go out as an NFL quarterback and if you want
to go out and do some blow in it in a titty bar.
Yeah.
Here's this one.
I can't stand about fucking people today with their phones.
If they saw the local quarterback doing blow in a titty bar,
he was fucked.
Rather than thinking,
well shit,
I'm here to,
you know what I mean?
No.
They will literally filmed the fucking guys who go,
oh my God,
I can't believe there's a starting quarterback.
It's like,
what do you do?
You work with heavy machinery.
Yeah,
it was,
what the fuck do you do?
You're fucked.
You're in the titty bar too and like the whole like,
just let somebody go out,
have a good fucking to shut the fuck ups like this.
Everybody telling on everybody just,
they're just so fucking mad being Jimmy John's managers and shit.
It's just like the guy.
If you can be a Jimmy John's manager and you can have a hell of a fucking,
exactly.
You could tell a week,
you could have a fucking weekend that would make Tom Brady be like,
get the fuck outta here.
Well,
Tom doesn't do that.
Tom's that doing that to me.
He's not going out and getting fucking nuts.
No,
I'm not saying what I'm saying.
He should be able to,
oh,
I have a second.
You said that.
All I thought about was Ken Stabler.
I heard this great story.
He used to play for the Oakland Raiders,
uh,
before that horrific trade where they got Dan,
pastor Ed and they switched and both,
and he became an oiler and finished up at the saints I believe.
And uh,
he farts fullest.
That's today.
Yeah.
No,
I,
that's all I did was looking football cards back then.
So it's,
coach was giving them shit one time cause he went up booze in the night before.
He's just like,
it went to fuck.
He going out partying the night before you have a game.
He just goes coach,
he goes,
how many hours sleep and you need to go play a couple hours football.
That's,
that's awesome.
And there's nothing to say.
You're right.
Doing those guys used to go out there and they would just fucking sling it like
I,
I don't know.
So anyways,
um,
real quick.
How far into this hour?
Half Hour.
Fuck.
At some point I've got to read some advertising.
So when they finally fucking winning.
Are you with other eagles fans?
Are you crying?
He attacks you in stunned silence by yourself.
Where'd you watch the game?
I'd ever,
do you remember that casino we played in San Diego?
We flew in a helicopter is north.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Oh,
you were there.
So we were there.
The girl,
I'm dating a girl,
I'm saying,
the lady friend,
she's like,
I know you're not going to want to be around anyone,
so I'll get your old tail.
So she got us a hotel and then she's like,
I want to sit by the pool.
So
Realistic Cabana with the TV.
It was fucking awesome.
We had a whole entire Cabana just herself.
I don't know,
putting pressure on the relationship,
but you've got to marry that girl.
I couldn't believe it.
She goes,
she's a Steelers fan.
She loves softball too.
But she goes,
I get it.
She goes,
this is your fucking day,
dude.
She's like,
I understand.
I know I could.
How many times have you said to a woman,
I get it.
And you were right and you made their day.
No,
I'm telling you what she,
when I said to assign a woman that gets a guy,
totally said to her,
I go,
you can totally buy my love.
I'm all,
I'm all for it.
So I never daydream.
Classic Guy.
She does something great.
Something sweet.
I can say ish,
maybe a little bit,
little bit.
So I,
I don't every day drink.
That's one of the reasons why the Rosebowl thing is out the window.
Cause I,
I'll give you see me when I'm drunk.
Do you think that's why you've never been?
What do you made?
Because the reason they're actually,
I'm going to come clean.
Okay.
We've never had you there.
Well,
the first couple of years.
No,
you've never been there?
no.
I'm saying the first couple of years you say,
hey come.
I said,
I don't think I got to know you better.
I told you.
And then we had a talk,
me and Bartner,
we're like,
listen,
we love Shea,
but the year we bring Shea is the year we get kicked out in the first quarter.
And I emit,
I told you guys that I even told far lane I go bar in it.
And if you,
if I come and I'm start drinking at 10,
oh it's done 10,
seven,
we get down,
it starts,
how the fuck do you mean go to the game?
I'm always blown too.
I literally drink,
pass out,
wake up with a hangover and recover before the game even starts.
I still can't believe its Sunday.
That's amazing.
I always fall asleep on when lie had light.
Always make some fucking insane.
Uh,
like for,
for the,
for the main course.
I never make it to the main course.
I always wake up,
it's already over.
I mean one year I was so shit faced.
I actually had the afternoon his cigar first and then all of a sudden he brought
over like a pork shoulder and I was smoking a cigar shifts.
I'd eat pork shoulder with my hands and occasionally I would look up and see
families walking by with children.
Oh my God.
I was just like,
wow man.
I remember going to Sullivan Stadium back in the day and seeing guys like me.
That's amazing.
Oh real quick.
So I got wasted by yourself.
Why?
What are you drinking?
Jameson soda all the time.
James and soda.
And she's facing the room.
The bed still made,
right?
Oh No,
no,
I'll come back and seeing the Cabana.
Oh the companion.
That's a banner with no shirt,
just shorts,
no shoes,
a hat and just a drink in my left hand.
And then there's other command and next to us was all patriots fans.
They were all like big white dudes.
Oh God.
But they were,
they were great.
They were like nice guys.
Cause I,
I became the loud one.
Obviously I became nuts.
So there's one guy who was like,
this big fat,
why do the beer every time you walk by the Taiko go pass?
I go,
Eh,
I couldn't even speak.
I was just so angry.
I'm like,
Eh.
So at the end of it.
Well,
he's being an account.
Yeah,
I know he's been a cut,
but he actually came up fat white country.
Yes,
exactly.
But he came over and he was really cool.
He shook my hand and congratulated me.
But by the end of the game,
dude,
I lost it.
I started throwing the,
flip it over the lounge chairs.
Oh God.
Yeah.
You know why?
Cause I was just fucking excited that that's how I get,
so I just started flipping over.
Do you think that that eagles fans are really that bad or the rep was there so
now they just try to find the guy eating horse shit.
You gotta Admit Horse Shit's pretty big.
That's all fuck is
sports fans are bad.
The whole line,
those fans are pedestrian compared to out here.
We'll clue fans.
Dude.
You fucking,
you can get killed out here.
A guy got killed at a Dodgers game doing a gut feels by,
they'll throw full beers that year.
They'll dump went over your head.
You want to get to a fist fight.
They'll do that.
A guy built like a farm animal shit.
Evidently stab at a Raiders preseason game like greatest 40.
Niners fuck cares.
I'm so sick of the fucking snowball is Santa
the fuck.
You know,
and I was making fun of who gives a full time?
You guys are in a big game,
like the big cheesy thing.
Whenever Boston is in a big game,
uh,
what they talk about is they'll talk about,
um,
you know,
they'll show like fucking the Paul revere statue or something in north end.
All this shit that nobody from Boston ever went to unless you went on some field
trip that you've,
that you've probably psyched as a kid because you didn't have to go to school.
The freedom trail and the foliage and fucking some lobster fishermen Tyna
sailor's knot.
I don't even know why I didn't get to what they do.
You guys,
it's always,
ah,
you know what it is?
Rocky statue Philly cheese steaks.
Yes.
No Buy Sienna.
I'm like,
did you just say Pennsylvania is a fucking young,
that's Tyler.
Go to Philly.
Next time I go to Philly,
I'm going to go on one of those fucking cheese steak places.
I'm going to say this.
Hello?
I would like a Philadelphia cream,
a Philly Philadelphia cheese steak sandwich with peppers and onions and
provolone cheese.
Please.
Sure.
I'm so sick of them telling me how to you guys you'll be a Wiz with,
I'm not saying that his so soup.
I have legal tender.
Make me a fucking sandwich.
It's the only city that's like,
oh,
in Boston you want some clam chowder and you gotta go so stupid.
I'm like,
I don't care.
I love Philly cheese steaks.
I'm from Bethlehem,
Pennsylvania.
I love him,
but I don't love him enough to say this is what I'm about.
I'm not a fucking Hoagie.
Can I tell you something to,
Oh God,
I hate clam chowder.
Clam chowder tastes like it was in,
you know what it tastes like.
Fixtures.
Nobody's,
you know what he said?
Shit.
That cow's chew one of the in between their three stomachs and they just Yak and
a ball.
That's what the fuck it tastes like.
You took it to another level.
Uh,
I like clam chowder.
Fishes,
fishes to me still seems like it'd be clear
across every part of the ocean.
Would be foggy
there.
Exit clear.
They got clear.
Just I like,
I like clam chowder and I don't even like Gnocchi Shit.
I'm like lactose intolerant.
I liked clam chowder.
I,
but I know it's not a big deal like Philly cheese steaks that it's just so
fucking nuts and they show it cooking.
I'm cooking.
It will gain core cut of meat.
I actually,
I liked,
I really like cheese sticks,
but uh,
I just hate that whole fucking thing.
You gotta say it this way now?
I don't,
I,
I haven't played affiliated so fucking long.
I don't,
I've never eaten into any of those places.
All right.
Yeah.
I stay away from home.
I gotta I gotta tell you something.
I got fucking,
you know,
when I got this old truck,
so I listen to fucking am radio.
So it's just a sports talk.
Uh,
somebody's speaking some sort of Korean or like political shit.
Yeah,
right wing stuff.
So I'm listening to the sports talk and they were talking about that,
whatever that fucking,
whatever our coordinator,
his name is Josh Assam Shit.
He interview annuals,
interviewed for the colts job.
All of that,
all of that shit.
And then he,
then he walks away the last second and then,
then they're talking about it.
And this one guy's going like closer.
You know,
there's not an illegal bar.
Uh,
I don't like the way it went down,
but the blah blah,
and this other guy on the show,
he goes
[inaudible] uh,
the patriots,
once again,
bending the rules.
It's like,
you've gotta be shitting me.
It's like they'll,
the level that people didn't pay attention to deflate gate.
It's like what that guy did to us,
if that's all we do.
Back to,
let's just say that was a conspiracy.
Yeah.
Okay.
Josh,
you're going to go in there and even though we're preparing for the Superbowl,
fuck all of that,
we're gonna have this big conspiracy and we're going to just waste their fucking
time if that's all we did to them,
he got off easy because it's $1 million and to draft picks over some bullshit.
You guys deserve that.
Why I'm fucking with you.
Yeah.
All right.
But here's the thing with the open,
you had a point,
I could actually become the piece,
my favorite thing,
but cherry on top of that story,
the Cherry on top of that story is not that the fucking idiot found deflated
balls on the cold side too.
It's that the fucking guy in the cults that caught the ball,
the initial one that started all that bullshit alleged,
listen,
this.
Yeah,
that guy.
You know what he did in the next year,
the two years within that he tested positive for steroids where it was ESPN
there you still are mad.
You won the Superbowl that year.
Like no,
he didn't.
Gate did.
No,
they
[inaudible] remember we did for four years.
You're talking about the suspension or placate happen and then that.
Then the next year like he got his fucking suspended.
Then they went to court,
blah,
and then it got up there and then he got fucking suspects.
It got laughed out of court.
The judge was mad,
you're wasting a fucking time.
Then the NFL was blood hurt that we beat them and then they fucking come back
and they go,
art is the NFL Corporation.
Yes.
Is Tom Brady employee of does a corporation,
right?
To suspend an employee.
That's how they spread and they found a loophole.
Thani got suspended.
I was like three years of shit.
Fair enough.
But we wasted fucking a week of that guy's life and fucked him over and season.
Fuck that guy.
All right,
fair enough.
I'm like,
I don't like the colts.
I agree with you,
but you've got a super,
I don't mind cold fans.
[inaudible] fans.
I don't really do we want to work?
We want would've got the fucking Superbowl anyways.
Yeah man,
we not,
we did do what?
No,
you don't want.
And then the 49 is when I had to spend all that money on a guy who's played five
games.
Oh,
grappa low Jesus Christ.
That,
what are they doing?
What's going to be good?
You know,
he's going to be good grappler.
He's he,
he looks like he's going to be ah,
dude,
this Benz.
I'm not saying he's not going to be good,
but dude,
that guy's making more money than like Aaron Rodgers.
I,
you know,
I do disagree with you.
Tom Brady would not have played as well if he just gets suspended those first
four games.
Two years ago I listened.
I will say this,
I liked,
uh,
39,
four year old guy getting four games off.
He like,
that's great,
but I don't think it added any more.
He Dude,
he's like psycho driven anyways.
My only thing about him is I don't want them to go out like Brett Farve.
I don't cause this whole fucking thing,
Tom versus time.
If he plays these 45,
you know,
as long as he's still competitive,
I just don't want to see him like on the rams,
like Joe name of fucking Johnny Unitas wearing a fucking charges uniform.
How's,
he's too proud.
He won't.
I hope he doesn't do that.
Why the fuck is he doing this weird reality show?
I don't get it.
What is,
what is I,
I'm not going to pay attention to it,
but that makes me fucking nervous because he never did shit.
Peyton manning did like 400 commercials a year.
I thought that helped us.
Yeah.
Because Hayden is kind of like that.
Every guy,
like,
he comes off like a dumb farmer,
Amy and people like Dan fucking Midwest.
I fucking hate.
I can't,
I don't like to cults in general.
I don't want to have to beat the chargers.
That's what I would have sunk.
Somebody asked me today like,
Hey,
you know,
where does,
uh,
where does it,
this is just going to be all football talk.
Where does,
where does,
uh,
you know,
Tom Brady having the greatest coach of all time in the,
in the brief versus Peyton manning argument.
And that's a fair point.
But,
um,
I be honest with you,
I actually liked Eli.
I would rather have had eli in January.
Yeah.
Eli's a better,
uh,
play off quarterback.
Then Eli,
his breath doesn't stink in September or October.
But then when,
you know,
do I need him to turn it off?
Turns it on Dan Marino.
Wouldn't you say,
man,
he's the greatest regular season quarterback of all time.
Uh,
first of all,
Dan Marino gets an unbelievable bad rap.
Okay.
Peyton manning was part of a three headed fucking monster.
All righty.
One that said,
we will know just by Edgerrin James and,
and,
and what's his face there?
Wide Receiver.
Just forgot his fucking name.
Marvin.
Marvin Harrison.
He never had his football card,
so I'll never remember.
All right.
Shot to view.
No,
he didn't.
He he legend.
Legend.
Well maybe they,
maybe they ate is horseshit and he was upset.
Um,
they fucking,
Dan Marino had no running game and note defense.
Yes.
Great.
His entire career.
What was he supposed to do?
I'll tell you right now,
Tom Brady would not have won a fucking Superbowl with,
with fucking and Don Shula.
Everybody stole all his tricks.
By the time the two they have a read would have thrown easily per 6,000 yards in
today's NFL.
Well,
Do you like it now?
Now I don't like it.
Pay went too far and when I'm liking about watching these first Superbowls is I
like more the running.
I liked the diff defense has had nicknames and stuff.
It was,
it was a meaner game and it was a more strategic game.
And to Paul verse,
he said the funniest fucking shit about that Eagle's patriots super bowl.
He's like,
dude,
he goes,
that's the kind,
that's the kind of game you're girlfriend likes.
Yeah.
Like if soccer had that much scoring,
I'd be like,
dude,
that was a great fucking care.
Then all those English guys would be like,
all right mate,
it's fucking belly.
But they wouldn't be able to break down the game as to why it suck.
Everyone keeps telling me what a great game.
Congratulations.
I'm happy because the Eagles won.
I'm happy.
But it wasn't a,
it was a shit show was a great game.
[inaudible] I said it was viewer friendly.
Yeah.
And I have to be honest with you,
that is all those rule changes.
I always blame to your mercy cause I'm a con,
but it's all of them.
It's because they're trying to expand the game.
And you know that they've done studies and you know that offense sells the game.
That's why I think MLB look the other way when everyone was all roided up and
they actually exerprise surprise all the owners get to act surprised.
Like,
oh,
we had no fucking idea.
I really like,
we don't know the comics set up partying.
Yeah,
the MLB does.
He pay the guy a zillion dollars a fucking year.
You don't know what he's doing,
but it's like the NBA by that game was fucked that,
that when they had the strike and they didn't have the world series and all of
that shit,
they needed something to come back.
By the way,
that was a fucking awesome mirror though.
W it was like,
it was fucking,
it was fucking amazing.
I remember Washington College,
every lunch,
every other in the cafeteria,
we'd watch the fucking I lights like who I went to.
Like I never,
I went through the same,
uh,
Mark McGuire hit his 27th or 28th home run.
It was down in San Diego on when they're still planting Qualcomm stadium as a
chef.
I went there with this Boston Common Dan Smith that we were sat in the upper
deck.
I went fucking McGuire to,
but the place was packed for his,
uh,
for his,
when he would take batting practice and the whole place he came up to the plate
for batting practice,
standing ovation.
It was like three quarters phasing for band practice.
Everybody's going us this,
the funniest shit ever.
The first pitch.
And he laid down a bunt and everybody boom.
And then he laughed and everybody laughed because it was kind of a cool way to
get rid of the stress.
Let me,
I've got to read a couple of,
uh,
advertisements here and then I want to talk about what's going on with
mailboxes.
What I'm gonna talk to you about it.
All right.
The Black Tux.
Everybody.
Kevin,
this is the black Tux.
The like the Ohio state.
You heard I am Greg Wilson,
d Greg Wilson.
I loved the Greg Wilson.
Greg.
He's a nut bag.
Yeah,
he's the best.
Uh,
everyone wants to look as great as their date at a wedding or special event.
Now they're talking about wearing a dress.
Trouble is there's no way you want to spend the amount of time or money she's,
she did shopping for outfit.
I can't read out loud.
By the way,
the black box.com is your answer with high quality rental suits and Tuxedos
delivered to your doorstep.
The Black Tux is the easy way for guys to rent suits and Tuxedos online suits.
Usually retail for 1200 bucks.
But at Black Tux they start at just $95.
God Damn Huh.
I'm going to get a Tuxedo.
Where do on my podcast expert customer care has you,
has your back every step of the way.
Completely done online with the Black Tux.
Free home.
Try on.
You can see the fit and feel the quality of your suit months before your event.
After ordering your suit,
after ordering your suit will arrive 14 days before your event.
If anything else is less than perfect,
the black Tux will send you a free replacement right away.
When your event's over,
just drop your rental back in the mail.
That's gross.
Shipping is free both ways.
Big Manila envelope,
uh,
to get $20 off your purchase.
Visit black docs,
black tux.com
that's the black tux.com/birth for $20 off your purchase.
The black Tux premium rental suits and Tuxedos delivered.
I love when people laugh at my reads when it's live.
It's too,
it's too hard to say.
What is that black Tux.
Z black,
black.
That's why you got to go.
You got to chop it up.
The Black Tux.
The problem you iceberg is,
here's another one.
Here's another one.
Simply safe.
I know this.
I've got some exciting news.
Simply safe home security company I've worked with since there we,
they were a startup.
Who the fuck was this for?
Um,
I've watched them transform into that.
Why do they do this?
Okay,
look,
they've transformed into the fastest growing home security company in the nation
protecting over 2 million people while they just released their brand new home
security system.
The all new,
simply safe.
Now this is the shit I'm into.
You got to have a home security system at this point,
right?
I don't understand.
They do.
You don't understand what they do.
I mean,
well,
I'm glad you asked.
You'd be great on an infomercial.
Wait a minute,
but does the x stick to the pan?
Of course not.
Just watch Kevin.
This system has been completely,
completely rebuilt and redesign.
They've added new safeguards to protect against power outages.
Yeah,
down Wifi,
cut landlines,
bats,
hammers and everything in between.
Remember the under Scarface?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No,
he wasn't doing all that blow.
That was a simply safe system and they saw all those fucking people coming over
the wall.
But Tony was too busy partying.
Tony,
what do you want to fuck me,
Tony?
The all new,
simply safe was redesigned to be practically invisible with the powerful sensors
so small,
you'll hardly notice them.
You know who will intruders.
This is what truly remarkable to me.
Evidently simply safe spent years building the system.
They added so much more.
How weird was that fucking scene that that poor actress had to play?
You want to fuck me?
Tony does hot now I know why you have a private computer for the point,
but you will still get the same.
Fair,
honest price.
24,
seven protection for only 15 bucks a month and there's no contract.
It's smaller,
faster and stronger than anything they've built before,
but the supply is very limited.
Visit simply safe dock birth,
Jesus.
Visit simply safe [inaudible] dot com now to order that's simply safe.
bird.com to protect your home and family today.
Simply safe bird.com one more.
Can you,
can you sit here?
I like it.
I can I interrupt you?
No,
no,
no.
You listen to Howard stern a little bit.
I like him to say I don't like then they like,
I like stamps.com stamps out comes easiest is the easiest way to access all the
amazing services of the post office.
Print postage for any male class right from your own computer.
The exact amount of postage every time.
Never under pair over.
Overpay against stamps.com saves you time and money,
which you can use to grow your business.
I can mail any letter,
any package using my computer and my printer.
Um,
and the mailman comes and picks it up.
The mail man last,
tag me to a stamps.com brings all the amazing services of the u s postal service
right to your fingertips.
Tips,
buy and print official US postage for any letter,
any package,
any class of mail using your own computer and printer,
they'll send you a digital scale that automatically calculates the exact postage
stamps.com we'll even help you decide the best class of mail based on your
business needs.
I use stamps.com whenever I send out my posters,
I a whore myself and I love stats on mold and groped by fucking cougars that
never,
never.
They brought to fucking trenches stamps.
Um,
well,
I don't know.
You fucking use a computer.
You have your assistant do it.
That's what you do actually and right now you too can enjoy some of somebody
born in the 90s you have do it.
And right now you too can enjoy the stamps.com service with a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus postage and a digital scale scale.
Go to stamps.com click on the microphone,
the top of the homepage.
Type in bird that stamps.com enter bro.
Use Your computer and your printer.
That's how you do it.
I don't have a printer.
Then you use,
you don't have a printer.
All right.
You know you went negative on all the ads getting a talk.
She don't need a home security system and evidently you don't mail mail shit.
I don't mail shit.
I returned.
I the only time I ever mail shit I have to return to fuck.
How do you pay bills online?
You Pay Online?
Yeah.
And do you use like your banking online?
Do you not do that?
No.
Do you?
You don't not fucking mail checks all the time.
You fucking with me?
No.
Do you know,
do you,
so you need soap?
Wait,
we'll hold the,
I'm one of the last ones because I was going to say is no fucking,
they're starting to get rid of mailboxes.
They're starting to weld them shut.
You go up to one,
you're like,
oh good.
And then you can't get it in there.
Yeah,
they're going away.
Like,
remember those,
those,
those phone books,
the big red phone booths that they had in England?
Yes.
And now for some reason they sold all of them over here because we're weird and
we want to,
so they turned those into the new mailboxes,
I think.
I think a bunch of people in England are going to buy an old post office boxes
and someone's just to come in their man caves,
so on.
Just bought the La Times.
So how the fuck are we gonna get the La Times?
If there's mailbox is don't work.
Don't you have a paper boy?
Oh No,
there's no paper.
Boy Wasn't there.
I do see,
I see a Mexican moms driving their kids around in the mornings,
in the mornings and they fill their fucking paper and God bless him.
And my dad used to do this with us.
That's why I have the work ethic.
I had a paper from third grade until the point it got weird.
Yeah,
I got,
my voice was starting to change.
I couldn't walk away from the money.
Oh.
My friends were always broke.
I do.
They had no overhead football cards and candy where my biggest fucking
expensive.
I wish wouldn't life be great if we could just get used to ride my bike up to
the bowling alley.
Go Bowling.
I paid for the whole fucking thing.
No.
Yeah,
never had to go to my parents.
He ain't [inaudible] me a couple of bugs,
man.
Never had to do that.
I was fucking independent.
Where you go and bill,
I've got on a bike ride.
All right.
Get the fuck Outta here.
They didn't give a shit.
We were,
we were born and you were,
but you were exhausted at school and guarantee I wasn't ah,
you were up at like four in the morning.
I rode a bike.
I didn't go boozing cause I was a kid.
My bought my body was brand new.
All right.
Premiere League football.
People write in,
they ask questions and all this shit.
All right.
Oh Nice.
I like this.
The Premier League football,
um,
the premier league,
I swear to God,
the level of excitement,
like whenever I put these games on,
every time when I watch him,
like,
you know,
they love it.
I can get into it and it's always,
it's always like nighttime and shit.
Nah,
makes you want to Bose.
You wish it was cold.
I he stuck on Ah,
fuck.
I gotta buy a scarf is just start singing some song.
I hate to be the cliche American,
but I don't,
I don't get soccer Sir William of Albino.
Phil.
That was actually pretty great one.
They usually just go,
hey Billy,
read Ted's.
Say you're freckled con,
you know,
usual.
I'd like that sir.
Alpine,
Oakville.
Um,
that's almost begging for a picture.
I think I got to dress up in a regal way.
I gotta make sure we wrap this up because I'm going to go see a Todd.
Rex is rex and he sold out both of his shows over,
sold them.
So thank you to everybody listened to Todd on this show and bought a ticket.
All right.
There is only one team you can support in the English premier league and that is
Liverpool.
Eh,
I'm just going to pause and wait for everybody in England.
Oh fuck.
A fucking kinds.
Beatle mania.
It is deeply working class with a long Irish history.
All right.
I'm in the city itself doesn't consider itself English,
but a separate entity from the rest of the country.
I'll grow the fuck up.
What are you,
the south you're going to secede from the union.
Liverpool football club is currently owned by Fenway sports group.
That's the red sox.
Yeah.
Up until recently we were the most successful team in England,
but a barren spell due to tragedy and mismanagement finally seems to be coming
to an end,
much like the red sox during their windless run.
Um,
so why the fuck do I want to jump on the bandwagon?
Now?
We are the most exciting attacking line in the league,
possibly Europe.
Our manager is an utter lunatic,
a very rich history.
Okay.
I'm kind of in right now.
Not all of it is good.
Uh,
including 18 league titles and five European cups.
The best team in the whole of Europe is European Cup.
We've been targeted by the press,
the media,
and even the government.
Oh,
this is like the Patriots.
Let us see.
I'm a fucking Liverpool Fan.
This isn't a franchise bill.
Once you pick your team or once your team picks you,
that's it for life.
No changing,
no moving cities through good and bad up the reds,
Billy boy.
Hey,
I don't switch teams don't even fucking suggest that I do that.
You fucking cunt.
Quite a,
yeah.
I was going to pick Liverpool just cause I liked the Beatles.
He was just trying to get you to switch to Liverpool,
my favorite Beatle song of all time.
Uh,
we,
we uh,
isn't that them?
Uh,
we,
we uh,
the Beatles.
All right views.
Do you get into soccer at all?
A little bit.
Well,
little bit.
World Cup,
World Cups.
Kind of fun.
Except that one year that one year in Africa and they had us [inaudible] that
was fucking horns.
Yeah.
What were those things?
Ah,
I don't know.
I didn't watch much of that instrument if like a Kazoo fucked up bagpipe
and Yoko ono played it all right.
Uh,
views on public speaking fees.
Hey Bill,
long time fan and listener and I always enjoy your point of view on things.
I'm that he just went straight ahead.
Yeah,
there you go.
Anyways.
Was listening to the most recent,
uh,
Monday morning podcast and I was surprised to hear your point of view on
speaking fees considering that you are inset in essence a public speaker.
I guess that you have some understanding how much more money this is relative to
other named acts.
I would be curious to see how much money other famous people get to talk if you
knew those without naming names.
Apparently Obama gets 400 grand per speech.
Uh,
no,
I'm not a public speaker.
I'm a coach.
I'm a comedian.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean at that point,
like somebody going like,
Eh,
you know,
extract stem,
you know about it.
I don't like the ones I like motivational speakers.
Yeah.
There's a reason that someone's called the public speaker.
What do you mean?
Because they're boring and they're not funny.
You're called the community.
We're actually entertaining.
It's like tedtalk.
Yeah.
Uh,
no.
My problem that I had with these guys say like Obama,
where everybody's looking at this guy like he's a fucking saint is he's doing
what all of these guys do.
They all go into public office.
They say they're there for the people and by the,
by the end of his administration,
he was already worth $80 million when he was making like four or 500 grand a
year.
But she got to make some,
I mean,
everyone wants to make money now.
Yeah.
But I mean they,
they,
they should give the president fuck you money.
I'm not upset.
It's the fact that I don't have the money to be like,
hey,
Obama know a Trump when you get an office,
uh,
makes sure that comedy club always has fresh Carol Marie,
his fucking 10 million bucks.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
Like they do,
except they do it on a fucking global level.
Is he asking how much performers get paid?
I don't know what he's,
I don't know what the fuck is asking.
On the flip side,
should we even care how much money they get after they're out of office,
sir?
Yes.
Oh,
you have to do,
how does the president,
again,
into office,
how does he afford to get into office?
He needs people to make campaign donations.
All right.
And when these fucking rich people make the donations and then after we,
after they're done and he does everything that they want to,
then they go on the tour.
That's them washing their bribe money.
Yeah.
Hey,
I'm going to give you a 400 grand to give an hour long speech.
Yeah.
The whole fill space.
It's,
it's,
it's so fucking out.
That's what it is.
I'm not,
I'm not upset that this guy,
I'm not upset that anyone can go out and make money.
It's just the fact that you've got these guys,
they need $100 million to get a job that pays for 500 grand a year.
And before that they make in 500 grand a year and by the end of it,
they are there already worth like 80 million bucks.
Like how the fuck did that happen?
Does that happen?
How does that happen?
How long someone should get to the bottom of how the fuck does that happen
because it's all fucking corrupt.
Um,
that's my problem,
sir.
And I think that the,
the,
the only true like really decent,
like truly public servant that I've seen as a,
as a president in my lifetime was Jimmy Carter.
I'm not saying he didn't go out and do public speeches.
I didn't even look up to that.
But the guy has spent his fucking,
his golden years where he could just be sitting there painting like fucking,
uh,
George Bush.
You know,
it can be out there tagging brides like Clinton.
He's,
he phase fucking building things for the home.
Isn't,
is shaking hands on an airplane too.
He's a fucking great dude.
Is that the guy?
Yeah.
And you know what's funny?
You know,
it's funny,
he was the most human,
you most humane guy I've seen and as a,
and he was considered to an absolute pussy,
but we know that's the truth.
That's how it works.
You can't be nice to not be considered opposed to no,
you can be,
it could be that.
You can be a decent thing about it is,
is he was nice enough when that whole fucking around shit,
what the hostages went down.
He settled that without getting dragged into a war.
So it was considered a pussy because big business could have gone in there and
made them money,
you know?
Yeah.
That's kind of not have to wait for another event to go in there and try to get
a bunch of fucking oil.
Alright.
Cheating with a boyfriend.
I like to,
yeah,
go.
Jeez.
Here we go.
Uh,
hey Billy burger.
It's cold
so we fuck,
yeah,
no,
no.
That's making fun of my last name.
That kicks me back to like grade school.
All right.
I'm a female.
I got a lady right in it,
by the way,
dude.
You're a fucking great guests,
man.
And you're a fucking great comedian.
Kevin Shea.
[inaudible] you gotta see Kevin Shay and listened to the old fuck dog.
Why wait,
wait,
wait.
Alls I'm saying,
Oh,
I'm saying,
oh no.
He goes all I'm saying.
Uh,
and where are you performing next?
Ah,
I'm at the Ice House Tuesday to,
Oh,
give me a fucking paid Gig,
man.
Oh Shit.
Um,
West Palm beach this weekend.
But that's a,
I'm with Ken Jones.
Can't John?
All right.
The guy from a hangover.
Well,
there you go.
There you go.
The improv.
Yeah.
West Palm Beach Improv Prof.
There you go.
There.
Go See,
go to Kevin,
shade.com.
Go to the Kevin Shade,
that TV,
some dark white guy in uppers upstate New York has given shit.
Kevin,
shade.tv and go down and check him out.
He's fucking hilarious.
All Right,
Bill,
I'm a female.
The story isn't about me.
It's about my friend.
Uh,
that's a lie.
I know my friend wants to fuck around on her husband.
We're in our early twenties and have been friends since high school.
We've always been there for each other and even though our friendship has been,
it has been long distance since then.
However,
now we have a slight problem.
Uh,
she's been dating a guy for a year and they've been butting heads lately.
One night she got high with her roommate who's a guy and they started to kiss
and then of course one thing led to another.
Apparently her roommate has been having feelings for her for a long time and
wants to be in a relationship with her instead of just banging her.
Uh,
she broke up with her boyfriend using their conflicts is the reason.
Instead of saying she cheated,
we've all done that.
Yeah,
we lie on.
All three of them have been,
have a bunch of mutual friends,
so she wants to lay low on the fact that she cheated.
She also wants to give her now ex boyfriend time to heal before he finds out she
staying in a roommate.
This is called being a class act.
Why bring extra hurt,
right?
Yeah,
but why not?
I mean,
at this point,
if she's feeling guilty,
just fucking say it.
That's easy to say at our age.
But when you're young,
when you're young.
Yeah.
Okay.
When you're younger,
you don't know how to do it.
She doesn't even have,
she doesn't even know that it's obviously her that she,
all right,
well let's going here.
I keep trying to tell her that would be better to come clean about what she's
done now than to wait it out.
I know.
Whatever their,
whatever their gender.
I know people in whatever their gender have the ability to cheat.
Growing up,
I've seen how being cheating on has affected people around me,
including myself.
I never thought that she would be the person to cheat.
So my question is
I people cheat,
whatever.
And then like now she's judging her.
Uh,
so my question is how can I get it through her head and she needs to handle this
situation better,
but also be a good friend to her at the same time.
Uh,
if need is there and has any advice,
it would be great.
Thanks.
And Go fuck.
Fuck yourself a second date problem.
Oh,
this is a different one.
Um,
you know what?
I think you need the bought out.
Yeah.
Well,
okay.
If we,
if we actually think this isn't about her,
which I don't,
I think it's about her and some are saying that to her.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
if it's,
if it's you,
this is actually the picture you would have worded it that way.
I believe it.
Okay.
If we believe it,
it's none of your fucking business.
You know,
people make mistakes.
We're all human.
So if she,
if you're a good,
this is the actual estrogen.
If you're a real fucking friend,
you wouldn't judge her.
Can I tell you something?
Once you get past the pain,
she did you a favor.
Yeah.
Cause you know you weren't married,
you didn't have any fucking kids.
You didn't have a house together and all that.
So who gives a fuck?
And then she,
you know,
they were already butting heads.
They weren't getting along was the end it and they were twins to that.
It's already over relationship and you go fuck somebody.
I mean it's still like girls.
You know what that's like.
It's like an empty net goal,
you know what I mean?
I mean,
I'll plot it,
but I mean,
you know,
you didn't fake out a golden,
it's garbage time.
We've got all this start is on the bench.
It's garbage.
It's garbage time.
Fucking,
you know what?
You have you ever,
I've done it.
I've had done me.
Oh God.
I found out later that I got man,
I was just like,
Eh,
it's a fucking,
was over
one more than that.
Whatever time you're in a relationship as it was over a half.
Like if you're in four years,
it's been done for two years.
Does that make sense?
I would say a year and a half year and a half break ups just don't happen
overnight.
You don't want to go with like,
you know what,
I'm fucking out of here.
You draw it out,
you start to get distance.
You start fucking this fucking course in how to break up in highschool,
ani in high school,
they should teach young people that are doing it would be so much better I
think.
Just so you don't fucking drag some alarm or you don't get dragged along.
All you had to do is you just got to sit down.
I've been one time I had to get out of relationship and I remember,
uh,
Steve Byrne had just got out of one.
This is like fucking,
you know,
years ago,
2025 years ago,
right?
And,
uh,
not 25,
like 20 years ago.
And I literally asked him,
I was like,
what did you say?
He goes,
I just sat down and said,
I just said I'm not happy.
That's what he started with.
And I've given that advice on here cause I use that.
I think I ever told him that I just
fucking used it.
I don't,
I,
we need to tell.
I'm just not like,
yeah,
I just,
you know,
it's just not working.
It just doesn't feel right.
I'm not happy.
And this is a thing,
but this is the thing.
You have to get it all out.
Yeah.
And I think we should break up and you got you like,
I think you just go boom,
boom.
It's like monkey bars,
boom,
boom.
Get across it.
And then you say,
we gotta break up and she's going to drag you through it like 50 fucking times.
It's like lying to the cops.
You just stick to your fucking story.
Yeah.
It's that whole,
I'm not happy.
I've heard it and I've said it.
It usually drags out for seven more months.
No,
but that's you.
It's no,
we're not happy.
It's not working out.
We need to break up.
You know?
I want to break up.
What the fuck it's done.
Yeah,
no,
I get it.
I get it,
but it never works that way.
Usually the other person is like,
no,
we can work this out.
Then that's when you have to go al Madrigal listen,
if you are living together.
Yeah.
If you're living together,
it's hard.
Then it's hard.
They're not living together.
You have to go al Madrigal wa now and no one ever told you that.
No.
I want to know.
Alan had a breakup one time.
The chick had some shit at his house.
He knew he was going to break up with her before we broke up.
You said he told her,
hey,
I'm going to come over tonight.
I think we need to talk about some things.
So she's like,
oh,
okay.
He fucking got a box,
packed all his shit up that was at his apartment,
walked over,
set the box down and said,
we got to break up.
It's not working.
It was fucking clean.
Yeah.
Over.
That's,
that's easy for al because Al as a fucking maniac,
like he does,
he,
when he has,
he didn't learn from maniacs.
No,
I love maniacs.
I've been kind of a maniac.
I are.
I am kind of a media cycle.
What are they willing to come to cycle when it comes to breaking up?
Uh,
they've never been good.
No,
it's good.
That's why you got to get through it.
If you live with them is harder.
If you don't live with them,
it's easy.
And that's why people fucking hang in and then they start cheating and they're
doing all of this fucking shit because they're basically mentally broken up.
So that a woman there essentially didn't even like,
as far as like an on an emotional level.
Yeah.
Didn't fucking on a physical level,
she cheated,
but on an emotional level,
she didn't cause she already fucking broke up with the guy she was done.
I find that when they're done,
here's one,
here's,
here's one.
When you know the other person was already fucking other people.
Okay.
When you,
someone breaks up with you and they're not even crying like that means they're
already cried it out with their fucking friends.
They got no tears left and it's just like,
wow man,
this is how long has this shit?
Yeah.
You know,
I've never cried at a breakup.
I can't.
And they get guys don't crow all,
all the girl,
all my ex girlfriend,
all my ex girlfriend's ex boyfriend,
they're like,
they cry,
they cry.
I was like,
cause they were fucking
pussies.
I was going to say the other words.
So I'm glad I did it,
but uh,
I would have known,
this is how I know this is how I know this is how I know when it's done,
when they kiss you goodbye in the morning.
Like,
cause I don't get off of work.
This is how I know it's done.
When,
when they're mad at you and you don't give a fuck.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You're like,
ah.
And they come in and they start doing the cold shoulder and they're not fucking
you.
It's just like,
hey,
like good,
good.
No,
you're right.
You're right.
Cause then you start getting more productive because you've got so much mental
time.
Oh this.
There's nothing worse than getting dumped,
but if you're the one breaking up with something,
I do it.
I've been on both sides of the broken hearts.
I've had my heart broken.
It's brutal.
I think that's why I'm so numb to it all now.
Yeah,
just fucking numb.
Oh No.
I already know if,
if my,
if my marriage is I've worked at,
I would never get married again and I would just give my wife fucking everything
and then I'll just go,
I'll go live in a fucking trailer.
My Buddy,
I'm not doing it again.
I'm,
I'm not getting on the fucking right again.
That's it.
Now.
Just fucking wherever she lives,
I'll just drive the trailer down the street so I can still see my kids.
You can send him one of those air pods.
You ever see those things?
I don't know.
I would get to fucking,
I buy one of those VW buses,
you know,
I get a studio.
They get all the sports packages.
That would be it.
I just,
I don't electronic drum kit.
I just go back to what the fuck I had.
I'm actually shocked that you got married.
To be honest with you.
Best thing I ever did.
One is great,
but it's weird.
I don't know.
I don't know if I'll ever get married to be honest.
It's like I want to get married,
but I don't know how to do it.
When you're ready.
Yeah.
I'm 42 I wasn't married.
I got married 45 I got three more years I'm going to,
it's great.
And then all of a sudden I'm like,
five years in,
I'm already going to turn 50 what the fuck am I going?
Actually,
where am I going?
What am I gonna go back to fucking,
there's a club.
This gray ladies,
you're looking for a bold red head and God is so sad.
I saw,
I see comics like that.
I don't,
I don't mention any names,
but when you see,
oh,
believe me do.
That was a motivation.
I'm not going to be the cliche.
It's so fucking sad.
I was like,
Oh God,
I don't,
it's so sad.
I'm like dating.
I don't,
I can't tell you I've haven't dated since I just started doing stand up really,
if that makes any sense.
Like I'd meet girls and then we just started hanging out and then I sent in a
picking them and that sounds weird.
You start why we start hanging out and then I just picked them.
I was like,
oh,
this is the one I'm going to hang out with this one for a while.
Do they know that's what you're doing?
I don't know if they do.
Yeah.
You need to listen to the first thing I am fucking learned is you just got to
fucking say what you're thinking.
Yeah.
You know that's one of the reason most of the women that I date like me,
cause I pretty much say what I'm thinking.
That's all.
How happy would you be if a woman did that?
That'd be fucking amazing.
I'm not saying like,
Hey,
you look ugly today.
I'm not saying that,
but I mean like,
you know,
don't,
don't be me,
but like just say to them one more time.
I,
the watershed moment,
my relationship was near had one of her friends was having a fucking birthday
party.
Yeah.
Right.
The same night the Celtics and Lakers were playing like game six of the NBA
finals.
Okay.
She's like,
why are you doing Tuesday?
Right.
She doesn't talk like that.
That's just how it sounds in my head.
So
what are you to see?
So I'm like,
I'm watching the game.
She's like,
ah,
does the pouty face,
you know,
the manipulations starts.
I hate this sexy voice.
And then the cow,
right.
So she's already tried to fucking tactics and not only is it friend having a
birthday party,
it's like some fucking 1920 steam birthday party.
So I have to buy a fucking costume.
Like a flapper.
Yeah.
I get addressed like I'm in the purple gang or some shit.
Right.
So she goes,
do you want to go?
And I just,
I said,
no,
I like that.
Yeah.
What do you mean no?
She goes,
why not?
I go,
it sounds horrific.
Yeah.
She goes,
and she laughed.
what do you mean?
She goes,
she's a friend of yours.
I go,
no,
she isn't.
I go,
she's your friend.
I've become friendly with her because you know her,
but she's not my friend.
I was sick this week.
She didn't know.
She didn't call.
She's not my friend.
Oh.
I just kept,
I just kept saying no,
and the more I said no,
the more she thought it was funny.
Who?
She got frustrated.
Then she just started laughing.
I go,
I'm not going fucking down at dress like Charlie Chaplin.
I want to watch this game.
I don't want to fuck a dues.
So then she was let go.
She can't,
she just,
she goes,
well,
what time does the game start?
I go,
just such an asshole.
Yeah.
So now I gotta go to this fucking party,
then race back.
So then I just made a compromise.
I said,
all right,
the game fucking starts.
Are you wet?
And whatever.
I said,
here's the deal.
I go,
I will drive you there.
I will make an appearance.
I'm not dressing up and I'm leaving with plenty of fucking time to get back.
Yeah.
So the before the game starts.
All right.
And I don't want,
here you go.
I don't want to hear that.
Once again,
that's not us.
She sounds,
that's how she sounds when she says shit like that.
So she said,
fine.
So I fucking show up.
I dropped a sing off on,
I show up and there's all these fucking guys,
their dress like fucking Charlie Chaplin and Al Capone and Shit.
And I come walking in with like a fucking Celtic shirt on,
dressed all regular.
There's like,
hey,
you didn't dress up.
I said,
no,
no mom getting out of here in like 10 minutes or they go,
where are you going?
I go,
I'm going to watch the Celtics game.
And it's the finals.
This fucking,
hold on.
I remember the look on their faces,
the secondly,
I felt awesome.
I bet there were so jealous,
dude.
You know what I do?
I've,
you know,
many times I've been the guy in the fucking Charlie Chaplin outfit.
I've always,
yeah,
then pretty hard about saying no.
Like I'll just say no.
Yeah man.
But then I,
I'm pretty good about compromise though,
if they want to do something important to them.
So as long as I get to do what I want and then if they have something,
yeah,
I know.
I have a bunch of compromises.
I have the,
okay,
but you're driving and I'm drinking.
Oh,
okay.
You go to Brunch if you drive and I can drink.
That's the thing,
you
know that is,
I still don't,
I don't do brunch.
Yeah.
That's the one thing I fucking is every time they walk there's a line and then
they walk in,
they come on and go,
it's going to be 40 minutes.
Is that all right?
No,
it's not.
All right.
This is my fucking day too.
And it's a Sunday.
Fuck,
it's a summit.
You're going to get pissed,
dude.
What the fuck do we take them to on a weekend where we walk out,
be like,
if they said it's going to be 40 minutes,
they would lose their shit.
Well,
they,
what bait?
They would gain their fuck out.
They would pow,
they would pop.
All right.
Do I have time to read?
What,
how far into this are we?
Fuck.
Alright.
Hour and 20.
We've got to wrap this up.
Um,
I'll read the rest of these some of the time.
Kevin,
this was effortless.
Oh,
thank you.
You fucking hilarious.
Leslie.
Funny.
And everybody should go out to the Improv and West Palm,
West Palm Beach.
More importantly,
listen to the podcast and listen to the podcasts.
All I'm saying,
all I'm saying podcast with Kevin.
Say One of the funniest dudes for the longest fucking time.
All right,
everybody,
go fuck yourselves and I'll check it on Thursday.